an individual moment of grief at the
police line in Colorado Springs
the community in mourning another
Community absorbing this nation's latest
mass shooting
beyond the tape a devastating scene and
a difficult investigation at Club Q one
of the city's gay venues a place where
people thought they could be safe
as a black kid you know it's taboo to be
gay so coming here this is one of the
first places that I've felt accepted to
be who I am I became a go-go dancer like
a lot of people got their start here a
lot of performers drag queens
is again it's supposed to be our safe
space
the police were on the scene in minutes
after the first 9-1-1 calls were made at
just before midnight
multiple teams were dispatched
[Applause]
by two minutes past the suspect had been
apprehended the suspect Andrew Club Club
Q and immediately began shooting at
people inside
as he moved further into the club
while the suspect was inside of the club
at least two heroic people inside the
club confronted and fought with the
suspect and were able to stop stop the
suspect from continuing to kill and harm
others this is the police stressed the
very start of a big investigation but
they did give some detail the suspect
has been identified as Anderson Lee
Aldrich a 22 year old male
at least two Firearms were found at the
scene we are still working to identify
the firearms and who and who they belong
to but I can confirm that the suspect
used a long rifle during the shooting
the injured were taken to several
hospitals some two or three to an
ambulance and some in police cars
the severity of their injuries varies
widely they have injuries from multiple
gunshot wounds and the like
what the nature of those injuries are
though we're all precluded from talking
about because of HIPAA and the
requirements to keep confidentiality
a statement from the nightclub said Club
Q is devastated by the senseless attack
on our community our prayers and
thoughts are with all the victims and
their families and friends we thank the
quick reactions of heroic customers that
subdued the gunman and ended this hate
attack
it is six years since the pulse gay
nightclub shooting in Orlando Florida 49
people killed the motive quickly
established a hate crime
the motive this time is under
investigation say the authorities the
suspect was injured and is in custody
was he known to police how did he get
his guns questions another grieving
Community needs answered Mark Stone Sky
News